let's go to the phones at 617-830-4750
starting with our caller from the old
stomping grounds of the david pakman
show
in the 4-1-3 area code who's calling
today from 4-1-3
hey david my name is i'm calling from
welcome massachusetts
um i had a question about
f1 visa ban like i'm not sure if you
heard about this
but ice recently updated their
guidelines and
they're basically saying that everyone
every campus which is opening only for
online classes and they're
saying that if the campus is opening
only for online classes and all the
international students need to
self-support themselves
or transfer to a college which is often
important that is basically
they're putting yes let me see if i can
let me let me see if i can explain it to
the audience and in the meantime
if we're on speakerphone or you're using
a bluetooth or something please turn it
off we can barely understand you but let
me explain to the audience what you're
saying
we there has been speakers can you hear
me
right now just just barely so what
what's going on
is many schools are going to be online
only
in the fall and what the trump
administration
is i don't think i can hear you okay
i'm going to let you go and then we'll
i'm not exactly sure what's going on
there but
maybe we can get a better connection
what the trump administration is saying
they are going to do is
if you are a foreign student here on a
visa
and your school is going online only
they are essentially
saying you've got to go you're going to
have to do your online classes from your
home country
it's becoming a very very big political
disagreement
and for important reasons and
we'll have probably a more detailed
report on it at some point in the future